today is a very exciting day we're in
the middle of another shoot right now
and there was a knock at the door and I
cried oh my god look I'm so excited
right now
my mics here I can't even oh my god I've
been waiting a really long time for this
okay I'm just gonna I'm just gonna push
it in look can you argue able to focus
on these years like this is I'm not this
good of an actress
this is real emotion oh my god I'm just
gonna push it I'm just gonna put you
might as well keep filming because I'm
so happy right now oh my gosh I can't
believe it's here early
[Music]
this is my iMac bro oh gosh
ah this is so incredibly heavy are you
ready
nice to match the outfit this is the
moment that I've been waiting for this
is not only just any iMac this is the 18
Core 128 gigs of ram beautiful beautiful
beats hold on I'm gonna flip it around
my gosh
hey there's will say I'm
over-exaggerating but I'm not this thing
looks so so good
[Music]
this is about this is a freaking beast
Oh
oh boy this is honestly this is this is
a moment here that we're all having
together we're sharing this this moment
we're sharing this moment as one Wow oh
god I kicked I get hurt it's okay
work through the pain Justine nothing
else matters except this right now I
cannot wait to get this thing set up so
it looks like it's gonna open up this
way even this is like a dark rake is
usually it's like a white little cloth
okay we've got our power cable let's
just open it up while we're here we're
here I'm here it smells okay the dog is
gonna love stealing that okay so don't
mind me just just let me I don't want to
I just went on make sure I get this so
happy what I know okay
oh there's more in here this is our
keyboard and mouse is there anything
else before I ditch this I'm saving this
box I usually get rid of boxes but this
is getting saved because it's beautiful
there we go down one would think it
would be easy
oh we are so beautiful Wow
wait to edit on this sweet sweet machine
let's say we got in here I already know
what's in here early
I act like I haven't watched every
single person that has done an unboxing
of this thing already looks me real I've
seen them all
oh the matte black keyboard oh and it's
the full keyboard - I haven't had one of
those in a really long time and and
here's our map like Mouse oh you sweet
thing
what I'm curious see is it did they
change up the design oh no they didn't
you still charge in here at the bottom
this is so glossy I forgot I got the
trackpad - I'm so glad I added this on
now this smells good this smells like
cinnamon
that smells like IHOP well through the
sound of course I forgot some things
[Music]
black lightning cable Apple issued and
what is in here already know what's in
here I'm just being silly a little black
cleansing cloth to cleanse my sweet IMAX
body and black Apple stickers my heart
heart it's beating at a very rapid rate
well it's only 84 beats per minute I'm
okay
Oh guys that's it this is the ANU iMac
Pro I've been waiting a really long time
for this this is definitely overkill for
an unboxing video oh my goodness it's
not swollen so I think we're all right
oh let's take this long we might as well
let's just take this off Oh get real
thin say those let's take this up - oh
you're gonna look so good oh yeah take
it off I've got that cleansing cloth oh
whoops
I wish Adele was here right now can you
imagine if she was here cuz I wanted to
sing to me Oh Joe
this is it this is the new iMac Pro it's
what I've been waiting for I'm so
excited about it oh man it looks so good
well thank you guys so much for watching
I will be doing a setup video here very
shortly unfortunately I'll be traveling
for the next week so hopefully I can do
that very very soon but in the meantime
I'll just be thinking about you
so nice smells like a fresh Mac mmm
I'll see you guys later
[Music]
you
[Music]